PROFESSOR: The example of
scheduling courses in terms
is really a special case
of a general problem
that you can probably see of
scheduling a bunch of tasks
or jobs under constraints
of which ones have
to be done before
other ones, which
is a topic that
comes up actually
in lots of applications.
But you can see applications
in computer science
where you might have a
complex calculation, pieces
of which could be done in
parallel and other parts had
to be done in order because
later results depended
on the results of an
earlier computation.
It leads us to the
general discussion
of parallel scheduling.
And we've already worked out
some theory of that really just
from the example.
Namely, if we look at the
minimum number of terms
to graduate, this corresponds
to the minimum amount
of number of stages or
the minimum amount of time
that it takes to process
a bunch of tasks,
assuming that you can
do tasks in parallel
and as many in
parallel as you need
to-- that there's no limit
on the amount of parallelism
allowed.
In that case, what we can say is
that the minimum parallel time
for a bunch of constrained tasks
is simply the maximum chain
size in the constraint graph.
We saw that example
with the course
prerequisites where we had five.
And in general,
this is the theorem.
Minimum parallel time is exactly
equal to maximum change size
for chains in the
graph that constrains
the order in which
tasks can be completed.
Now what about the
maximum term load?
Well, that corresponds
to the number
of processors you need to
be doing tasks in parallel.
So for the course
scheduling example,
it means how many subjects
can you take in one term?
But if you were, say,
doing computations,
how many separate CPUs
would you need in order
to be able to fully utilize
the parallelism to as
much in parallel as you
possibly could and abound
on the number of processors that
are needed for minimum time is
simply the maximum
antichain size, which
in the example from the previous
segment on course scheduling,
it turns out there were
five courses you could take
in one term, the second term.
And that was, in fact, the
maximum antichain size.
So that's an upper bound on the
number of processors that you
need to achieve minimum time.
But in fact, it's a
course upper bound
because although the
number of processors needed
to achieve minimum
parallel time is at most
the maximum antichain size.
In fact, in the
previous example,
it turns out you could get
away with three processors.
It was possible to
schedule the subjects
so you only took
three courses a term
and still finished
in minimum time.
So can you do better
than three subjects?
Well, there's a trivial argument
that says, no, you can't.
Because in that
previous example,
we had 13 subjects to schedule.
The maximum chain size was 5.
So it was going to take
at least five terms.
So that means you have
to distribute these 13
subjects among five terms.
There has to be
some term that has
at least the average
number of subjects,
namely 13 divided by 5.
So that means there has to be
a term in which you're taking
13 divided by 5 subjects.
Of course, you round up because
it has to be an integer.
So the minimum number of
terms to finish and graduate--
finishing these 13
subjects in five terms--
is 3 because 13 divided
by 5 rounded up is 3.
And this is a general
phenomenon that applies.
And what we can say is that if
you have a DAG with n vertices
and the maximum chain
size is c-- so that's
how deep it can be at most-- and
the maximum antichain size is
a-- that's the largest
number of things
that you could ever possibly
do in parallel-- then clearly,
the total number of vertices
is c times a, at most.
So the total number
of tasks that you
can do where you
are going to finish
in c steps using at most
a processors is bounded
by c times a.
So what that tells you
is that you can't both
have the antichain
size and the chain size
be too small because their
product has to be at least n.
That can be rephrased as
a lemma that is credited
to a guy named Dilworth.
Dilworth is actually famous
for Dilworth's theorem of which
this Dilworth's lemma
is a special case,
but we don't need
the general theorem.
Dilworth's lemma says that if
you have an n-vertex DAG, then
for any number t, it either has
a chain of size bigger than t,
or it has an antichain
of size greater than
or equal to n over t.
And we proved this on
the previous slide.
The product of these two
things has to be at least n,
and the general case
is t times n over t
is greater than or equal to n.
And this holds for
all t between 1 and n.
Well, let's think of a
simple application of that.
If I choose the t that balances
antichain size from chain size,
then I choose t to be
the square root of n.
So over here, I have
square root of n,
and here I have n divided
by the square root of n,
which is also square root of n.
And what we can conclude
is that every end vertex
DAG has either a chain of size
at least the square root of n
or an anti chain of size
at least square root of n.
This turns out to actually
have a few applications,
but we're just going
to look at a fun
application of this
remark that you
have to have a chain
or an antichain of size
at least square root of n.
You might have
only one of these.
You might have both.
But one or the other has
to be at least as big
as square root of n.
Let's think of a
new DAG that I'm
going to construct as follows.
I'm going to draw an edge
between students in the class,
and I'm going to
think of one student
as having a direct
edge to another student
if the first student is both
shorter and younger-- actually
meaning no taller than and
no older than the other.
Let's just say shorter--
meaning shorter or possibly
the same height-- younger
or possibly the same age.
And so the rule is if
I think of a student
as being represented by their
shortness s and their age
a, then a student
with a height s 1
and age a 1 has a direct arrow
to another student with height
s 2 and age a 2, providing that
the first pair is less than
or equal to the second
pair in both coordinates.
S 1 is less than
or equal to s 2.
And A 1 is less than
or equal to A 2.
Now, we don't want
ties here because that
would break the
DAG property if I
have two students with exactly
the same age and height.
So let's assume that we're
measuring age in microseconds
and the height in micrometers.
And with that kind
of a fineness,
the likelihood of a
tie is pretty low.
So then it becomes a DAG again.
So this is the definition
of taking a DAG built out
of pairs-- there's a
pure DAG for height,
and there's a pure DAG for age.
And I combine them into
pairs, and I get a new DAG
by looking at how the
coordinates behave together.
This is called
the product graph.
It's a general
construction that comes up,
and we will talk
a little bit more
about when we reexamined
DAGs in the context
of the language of relations
and partial orders.
Anyway, this is
the product graph.
According to Dilworth's
lemma, in a class like ours
of 141 students,
it means that we're
going to have a chain or an
antichain in this product
DAG of size square root
of 141 rounded up, or 12.
According to
Dilworth's lemma, in
this particular age-height
graph, what does
it mean for this
to be an antichain?
Suppose I take a
bunch of students
and I line them up
in order of size
with the tallest on the left
and the shortest on the right.
If this is going
to be an antichain,
it means that they have
to be getting older
as they get shorter.
Because if I ever had a case
where somebody to the right
was both shorter and younger
than somebody to the left,
it wouldn't be an antichain
because they'd be comparable.
So an antichain--
according to Dilworth's
lemma-- if you'd sort
the students by height,
they have to be getting older
and as they get shorter.
If it was a chain, they
would be getting younger
as they got shorter.
But the more interesting
one is the antichain
in this height-birthday example.
So we should be looking at--
we'll either have a chain
or an antichain in this class
according to this product DAG.
As a matter of fact, we
really had an antichain.
Here's a quick list
of a dozen students.
And indeed, if you
look at the birthdays,
there's somebody who's 6'1 was
born in August '94 and then
somebody who was born in April
'94 and is 6'0 all the way down
to somebody who was born in
1991 and who's five feet tall.
So we lucked out.
We could have only had
to chain, but we actually
had the antichain in this case.